Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier. And welcome back to "Dream Daddy".
Now we gotta get back into this cause Joseph probably wants his plate back.
*reading text*
I'm probably going to punch one of them in the face.
Oh they look... d-*disgusted noise*
-They look dower.
Hey!
Don't murder us.
*scared/distress sounds*
Alrighty then.
I need my sleep!
Ah.
*reading Dad tip* 'Don't do it once do it right'
Oh okay.
Oh I know this guy!
*Enthusiastically* Hello!
*drawn out* Bro!
Really great.
[Craig speaks]
Bro!
*imitating Craig*
Oh man.
*angrily* God damn it! Why does Craig gotta be so much better than me?!?
*frustrated/angry shout*
Ja-God-I gotta go-I gotta go
*laughing* exercise.
I gotta go for a jog.
I love Bro Brunch. Can we go Bro Brunch everyday?
*shouts angrily*
Why is Craig so much better than me?!?
Yeah I was just about to say he's not wrong. I guess that is what a tomato smoothie would be.
Aw.
*reading Dad tip* Don't judge the-okay.
*Casually* Or a boyfriend or whatever.
Wasn't that the dog we met in the park?
Is this a joke?
*reading* 'regret to inform you' Aw.
*outraged, shouts*
Hey! I'm cool!
I can get my trumpet out. We can start the Ska band again.
*flustered* I'm gonna go date some dads! I'm gonna go daddy datin'!
Let's see. Uh-
*reads over the choices*
I don't know if you know this, *laughs*
go-dance. Tear it up on the dance floor at the local club.
'Go out and wa-*laughs*
Okay. Who's Mr. Vega?
*reading Dad Tip*
What you do-
*frustrated noise*
I wanna know these Dad Tips! They're very important to me.
Hi-deda-this way.
This way. *says jibberish*
*Surprised gasp*
Jim and Kim's? What the hell is Jim and Kim's?
*burps*
*silly voice*
One beer for me to watch the game with!
Oh.
*excited, douche-y laugh, quietly*
That's me....me.
*Louder* That's me!
She seems drunk enough.
*nonchalantly* Oh whatever!
I can't drink. Drink for me.
'What's the latest gossip around here?'
Ya hear any cool stories about the people round this town?
Okay.
See ya, Mary!
*fake laughs*
Oh. Okay.
God that's a Dad joke alright.
*Gruffly, Seductively*
'I love shots' Clink-ies baby.
*fake laughs* Yeah.
*Gruffly, Seductively*
Oh yeah you're welcome.
*fake laugh* Yeah.
*laughs*
'Compliment his hand tattoo'? That is-that's very subtle.
'His rugged good looks.' Hmm. Too forward, not friendly enough.
I think that's just impersonal enough to start off this conversation.
Hey.
Nice jacket.
Oh.
*gruffly, increasingly louder*
Like a bad ass-I'm running from-I got a boo boo this morning!
*gruffly, shouting* I met a guy in a park. He had a cute dog, but he out did my Dad-proudness.
*gruffly* Scarred me for life.
Be right back. Gotta powder my nose with cocaine.
With me, what, liking The Game and whiskey and all.
*makes a blowing sound*
*surprised noise*
What?
Oh!
*Laughing* 'Lay it on smooth'
'Smile and Nod'
'No, thank you.'
*Laughing* Smile and nod. The-
Smiling and nod seems what I would do.
Just- 'yeah, uh huh'. Like, 'yeah. okay.'
*shocked* Oh.
'I follow him'-oh-oh God. *continues reading*
*surprised, excited laugh*
*grunts* Woah.
*confused* No?
*awkwardly, cheerily*
Well then.
That happened.
*Starts to read text*
*laughs*
Uh-oh.
I mean, I love pickles. I fucking love pickles.
*reading Dad Tip*
'A bird in the hand is worth'-*sighs* okay.
Excuse you.
*Sighs*
*Shouts outraged*
Hey! He's got my hairstyle!
God damn it! If they would've-if they would've had that available-I would've-*disgusted noise*
*fake laughter*
Hugo Vega. What a name.
*dejected, sadly*
Oh.
Oh boy.
*happily* Aw nice!
Nice.
Law-ya-long lady. Young lady. Young yady.
Let's go to the mall! *speaking rhythmically* Let's go to the mall.
Today.
Go to the mall.
One thing.
Similar situations in their life, given that they are older, and have been through things such as that.
[Amanda groans]
*imitates Amanda's groan*
*shouts excitedly* Is it a meme!?!
Is it one of those 'may may' 's?
I love memes!
*suspiciously*
Miss Protests Too Much.
*confident, fake laughter* Nice.
Guess the conversation's over.
To the mall then! Scoodalee-doo.
*high pitched*What? What's wrong with hell?
What's wrong with hell?
'Can you explain memes-' *shouts* I knew it was memes!
I called it! Memes.
*quietly laughs*
Oh shit waddup?
Oh.
[Amanda shouts]
*imitates Amanda*
Oh.
I should look at ironic mugs. Who doesn't like a good ironic mug?
Alright so I- I'm gonna-I going to end this episode here.
We've had a fulfilling day?
Lot of stuff has happened. And we're starting to accelerate our entry into dadhood.
But before that we've got a long way to go and a lot more dads to meme.
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you think of this down in the comments below, I'm having a wonderful time.
*Laughing* This game. It is so charming.
I love it so much.
So thank you again.
And as always, I will see you,
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
*outro music plays*